So what, what are the most important dos and don'ts
to keep in mind in data science? I think I
would mention two. One is a bit more, qualitative and
one is a, a bit more, quantitative. So, on the
qualitative side I, I would say the first thing is
any problem you're looking at, it's always very valuable, I
find, to start by thinking about. What sort of things
do we know? What sort of expectations do we have?
And what sort of qualitative things can we get from,
an exploratory analysis of the data? So, as I mentioned,
using things like k-means clustering and PCA are a good
way to start to do some sort of dimentionality reduction.
Some way of getting the data down to a point
where you can. Look and get some qualitative insights. Understand
the general structure of it. And quite often in, in
certain topics that we work on, you have some intuition of,
of what you'd expect things to look like.
You can start to see patterns, emerging data that,
you know, that makes sense. That, that. Either confirm
or, or possibly go against other theories or ingrained
beliefs that people have. so, so I think getting
data down to that point is very important. The
more quantitative suggestion I would have, has to do
with trying to understand causal connections. So, this is
a very common thing that comes up. In building predictive models you
may have a number of features. That you put into a model to
predict some outcome. And it's very, very important when doing that. So, often
the question comes out not just being able to predict an outcome. But
understanding which features are actually causing it. It's important to use a
lot of caution around that. To never just sort of, dump a bunch
of data into a model with lots of features, and then just naively
look at the thins that have the strongest weights in your model and
say, oh. Here's what's driving it. So, it's very important when you're
asking those kinds of causal questions
to proceed very carefully and, and rigorously.